[Music]
citizens of the r Nation it's me TI
Ericson
alongside I'm Batman what his name's
Aaron Alexander and he just sounded like
a monster a
monster we're watching saw six today we
have watched 1 2 3 4 5 and now we're
watching six that's a lot you got to
remember okay because of all the hard
work we've put in Saw and stuff you got
to like you got to leave a comment and
you also have to ring the
bell ring the bell also thanks prepper
for helping us edit down these videos we
love you so much don't forget also I
keep saying don't forget like there's
just so many things you guys need to
remember if you don't know this already
we call you super sexy on patreon so if
you join up you become a patron you get
sexy in your life do you feel sexy right
now Aaron I feel super sexy he feels
super sexy he has a Batman ones on and
we're not even going to talk about it um
um cuz we don't need to um and uh I mean
what we just need to get into s people
right are we ready let's get into
it good old Twisted pictures they
weren't here until saw right they didn't
really they weren't right wasn't it like
or was it Lion's gate no I think I
learned that lioncap first film was saw
oh I think I learned that you guys can
tell in the comments if I'm wrong or not
I didn't know that I think I might be
right I would I would believe
it okay what's what's going on here o
fingers a roach on a
hand oh yep I thought it was a ring at
first I don't no
no always begin with a head
trap
uh-uh now what does she do why is she
here
okay so like they're going to be
lobotomized right those things are going
to yeah yeah that's what that looks like
Edie wake up oh she knows him move don't
lean forward this what's what's going
he's going to do it of course he is oh
okay I want to play a game the devices
on your heads are symbolic of the
shackles that you place upon others you
recklessly loan people money oh counting
on repossessing more than they could
ever pay back only one of you may pass
before you are the instruments to EXA
this flesh all right ah cuz they're lone
sharks the most flash will release their
bindings while the gears will engage
piercing their skull just start chopping
y'all come on now hands
feet I'm not dying for you oh my god
rude damn I so col
oh oh God he's not going to be able to
do it you can do it girl you're so much
more fit than him you're so you're
you're out he so much more to lose
you're running you're
strong he he has more meat to be able to
take off that's true he he could be
there a while oh she going to go finger
straight for the fingers oh good good
for her though cutting off her her uh
not her fies no okay her
blood oh
oh what I told
you he has more fatty
moose look like a steak oh my
goodness you're not about to C off your
damn hand come on oh my God he's going
to bleed out I mean she at least cut off
her blood her
circulation oh my God that looks intense
prep Department
hello
oh no I hate it
no oh my God damn your
arm yeah yeah yeah yeah yo that's wild
that's
wild no I don't want
it oh my God oh my God it takes that
many many God that many jobs
why girl you better put that arm in
there stat let's go oh my goodness one
arm versus like oh four slabs of fat no
come on
now warm arm takes it has bone in there
has bone in there you're done
buddy you're done my
guy you shouldn't called her a [__]
dude I motivated her karma yep
woo all right I did not know that it
took 54 chops with a butcher knife to
take off your arm have you learned
enough to trust me for if you do not
this room will forever be your tomb oh
yeah homie's dead your body will never
be found he
got crushed by walls this was gnarly
Nicholas got caged yep
yeah gnarly hate that hate
why we got to see it
again
damn damn oh God
what I don't like it I really don't like
that we still don't know what's in the
box right the wife with the yeah the
wife got Bo with her little necklace key
mhm I've got to work late again well I
got to meet with legal that's going to
jam me up for certainly the rest of the
afternoon and I got to f up my secretary
here I got to put in some mad overtime I
know it's your birthday I'm going to
make it up to you I promise it's her
birthday I hate him you suck we're
talking about your deposition when
opposing Council asks you about Mr
Abbott how are you respond this is my
job to review every terminated
pulse uh I just oh I love him when we
reviewed your claim we discovered that
you failed to mention a previous
condition you had oral surgery to remove
a cyst from your jaw this is absurd I
have heart disease what right surgery is
going to leave Scar Tissue Scar Tissue
can lead to gum disease and as you well
know gum disease can cause heart disease
I paid my monthly premium for 10 years
without so much as a cold and now that
I'm actually sick you're going to deny
my coverage what I'm sorry but your own
actions have caused this can't wait to
see him die so so harshly brutally
everybody thinks we're the Bad Guys
nobody mentions that for the millions of
dollars we donate the charity every year
or all the free clinics we
support the assets for one of history's
most notorious serial killers John
Kramer were distributed who found the
error on his application the dog pit
they work as a
team there's a discrepancy to be found
in an application six of them will find
it oh the six of them are going to be
found in a room tied
up wait is that
two oh shoot no that's not Theo that's
um from another sicom from the '90s this
guy practically lives at his doctor's
office I mean this could probably save
us nearly 200k over his life oh Eddie
from um Family Matters there you go yeah
found
it
Erics we also got a right index off the
scale Aran strongs when I learned that
he and as were being targeted by jigsaw
don't tell him this we have something he
doesn't know about oh
Lord
Lindy detective Hoffman oh she survived
oh my
god
wow nice so you let me think she was
dead well I didn't know who I could
trust we like to work together on this
we're offering full disclosure detective
from now on everything we know you know
ah don't do
thata Jenkins the resident jsaw
Sensations I know more about John Kramer
than you might think kmer left his wife
a box in his will did you know that
what's in the box what's in the box girl
what do you really want Jill tuck help
me get to her and I'll dial down on the
sensationalism I'll see what I can do
moved in a little close for that last
line right see what I can do flirtatious
without in more ways than
one who did this jigsaw you didn't your
own arm off but he made me do it and why
is that what Eddie and I were doing was
wrong he wanted us to learn and did
you B at my damn arm what the am I
supposed to learn from this huh damn I
think he wanted you to not you know over
people anymore with financial situations
that are bad I know
right YY here we are hey Kitty here's a
little happy
family we love you son we're waiting for
you oh God what if what's in the box is
like their Taxidermy son their Taxidermy
son yeah like it's like their son but he
they was like embalmed and then put in
this box oh god oh I hope not I wouldn't
put it past him or if their son is Billy
the
Puppet what is it
come on
now 5 4 3 2 it's all those people the
six people in the pen right maybe no in
the bullpen that make the decisions for
the insurance oh your brain's moving
it's probably wrong
though Pamela Jenkins calling yet again
I was hoping you could clear some things
up for me about your husband let me buy
you lunch or a cup of coffee these are
the jigsaw pieces cut from previous
victims they're different this is the
piece taken from the latest
victim it looks like all the rest it's
all wrong they're indicative of a knife
with a partially serrated
edge all of the other Cuts were made
with a near perfect blade of surgical
quality same knife was used in only one
other victim Seth
bter oh you can tell a different knife
is used from a photo no but I
can I was the one who examined in that
body they're coming on to you buddy
we're looking into the Seth Baxter tape
if a different person cut the piece then
maybe a different person made the tape
too strong yeah
maybe she's on to you she knows she
knows something change of plans the game
begins tonight because somebody knows
about the box that shouldn't so from now
on I control all aspects of the game
it's not what John wanted oh huh oh snap
she knows he's in on it okay
here but that's not all of them what's
in that yeah from now on I work alone
I'm only carrying out John's final
request well Jon's dead and his work is
almost done my work begins these people
have no respect for the lives that
they're destroying once you see death up
close then you know what the value of
life is and that's my way and I brought
proof this is how he's like prepping her
to like
Amanda
oh you once told me that she was a lost
soul oh cuz she was at the facility
that's how found her she at it right oh
wow it works it's real wow he helped me
except she's got all her limbs still
it's a different kind of learning okay
so since Amanda she's been well now
she's getting into like being a full-on
Believer but yeah well clear she's know
about longer than we've we've known we
known yeah the jigsaw killer may be dead
but the murders
continue they're coming for you you and
all your blood
Money Carma is a
[__] you better run oh he got a gun oh
dang okay all right than this is
spooky don't
move okay it's just the
janitor security oh my goodness of
course you killing security guard
[Applause]
bro all right got him that was a good
bait and switch
there what is this one okay all right oh
no oh this isn't going to end well what
is this oh he gets crushed in the middle
no joh oh he's just showing his face on
the tape okay that's new he's letting it
all hang out right hello William you've
probably been wondering when we would
see each other again today is that day
the healthy have benefited while the
potentially sick have been unjustly
rejected and you have four tests you
must complete or if you don't the straps
on your arm arms and legs will
detonate just as you have taken loved
ones away from their families if you
don't reach the end before the timer
hits zero you will never see your family
again okay the game's begin where are we
I don't know what is this I don't know
look oh God they have to watch him no
thank you oh jeez H that's rough your
health with an hereditary background put
you in the highest category of
success W oh oh okay this man has
continued to smoke even though he has a
history of high blood pressure every
time you take a breath the clamps around
your chest will close in oh
gosh you got to just suck in a breath
and hold it hope forever you know how to
do it hope for as long as you can hope
you're a good swimmer I mean the smoker
is not
this game what you think that's his
family the the this guy I think it's the
money guy's family in the box right
yeah yeah we all saw that coming oh
Lord that's not that's not fair jigsaw
like also this guy's skinnier like the
money guy skinnier if they're set the
same equid distance it's not a fair game
I'm sure he counted for that you think I
mean I assume he would the engineering
of it but
oh Lord oh Lord I mean the janitor
wasn't even hurting anybody else's life
he just damn the man
himself yeah okay can this just be over
already oh my God this is just torture I
don't I don't want it let's just just
yeah just keep breathing just end
it no oh my God so sad you just killed
that guy for no reason man Oh my he
wasn't hurting anybody he's hurting
himself but damn he doesn't care oh
Jesus oh did he just have a surgery cuz
that looks sewn up yeah does huh yeah
with the stitches that's the worst part
that this trap wasn't even about the
other guy it was about teaching this guy
a lesson right and they had to utilize
an innocent Soul did you imagine just
like someone's life amounting to just
teach somebody else a lesson God don't
sign me up for that game please don't
sign me
up oh wow okay that was easy hey all
right but you also have to get the other
one off right or did he well I think
once he passes that one game I think he
should be fine right it's all puppies
and rainbows from here on out yep no
more death in a Saw movie everybody
learned their lesson and no one else had
to die anybody
live die yeah is that the dude from
rodri Rules is he I think the kids from
D of of a Wimpy Kid what does that stand
for hydr Floric acid oh God hell no no
it's going to burn your face off what
about the timer that has to mean
something I don't even know why we're
here we're here because of your father
yeah you know it he's not a good guy not
a good fella see we're here cuz you
missed her birthday M Jenkins please
this will only take a
second cat fight like what like well
hello FY sing you with this
hour does it mean anything to you
no if you think of anything I thought a
pig mask was about to come up and behind
her yeah I still think it is maybe
they'll just be right here he's behind
you around the corner here we go yep
yeah yep I've seen these movies I know
how this works we've been here what was
she going back for I want to thank you
for sponsoring this party when people
come to us for coverage we have to
analyze each person for the probability
of success you choose who lives or dies
but you're not taking into consideration
the most important human element of all
the will to live till a person has
played my games they really don't know
what life
is take
them
good well you should have listened uh
listen to that thing it's going to H
it's it's going to be like an alligator
right or something crazy there's still
animals what is it we haven't seen any
animals do in the Trap
yet oh
oh no that's scared me your file clerk a
young healthy male with no living
relatives the other a middle-aged woman
with a family history of diabetes your
secretary is older and weaker as worthy
to survive you must let go of one I feel
like the games end when everybody who's
wrong John while he was alive has played
his games has played
yes no I'm not going to die I mean
you're going to do it he's going to let
the kid go I feel like he's going to let
the old lady go cuz that's what he would
do in an insurance but I know we're
looking at the J position like he'll
choose the lady but I feel like he's
going to just let her
die oh come on
buddy he's choosing her oh wow okay
don't know yet he ain't made a choice
yet come on
buddy there losing him yeah
yep what what what does that mean yeah
he's
dead yeah I knew he was going to choose
cuz he has a family himself yes you try
to find a way out of here Addie I have
to keep going be
careful yeah yeah careful with a barbed
wire around your neck yeah this see you
this is starting to become a theme Now
with uh with
saw three four and now six like the one
guy going through like the trial of of
traps
[Music]
okay yeah where was their tape she has a
tape we found the Seth bter tape but
there was something else that we wanted
to discuss with you about you're the new
saw yeah I was like what's in that
envelope that she kept I need is that
the number six envelope it's like was a
seventh one I feel like oh no in this
movie it's probably homeboy himself in
there she has to do the last trap or
it's their son's
ashes the device Timothy is strap to is
my personal favorite I call from three
that was rough yeah that's pretty bad
last minute tweaks
what
oh fa do you like how brutality feels
Mark you want him to suffer just as much
as I do you've become corrupt you've
lost faith in the law when's your test
detective I don't need one because
I didn't take my life for granted what
do you know about life get used to me
cuz I'm not going anywhere okay Amanda
literally dies that that same movie as
this is taking place you're too Reckless
girl too
emotional damn she just she just up in
here she's just part of this now okay
she's just been in it don't do this I
promise you I will provide a way out for
you what's this for for the final
game I'm going to open that box
yeah what what is in
there great got you on
camera got you being sneaky on
camera I like the way this one is seems
um all handheld I haven't seen a whole
lot of um the dolly type of shots maybe
I have but I feel like it's more
handheld which I like also doesn't look
as TV as the yeah the other ones that we
were talking about my requests for
coverage have all been turned down at
your age and with the development of
your cancer it's simply not feasible
it's not feasible it's policy John get
out of here with your business talk get
out of here I don't understand Insurance
like this it makes me like gross so
gross out that this like actually
happens yeah don't talk to me about
money I have money this is about
principle you going to learn today mhm
lesson incoming even if the treatment
works the cancer will return eventually
it's an unwinable battle you think it's
the living that will have ultimate
judgment J M over you because the dead
will have no claim over your
soul foreshadowed threat from the grave
Tak in your soul you have seen the flaws
in your policy the lawyer from your firm
has 90 seconds to cross this room or the
device attached to her chest will
discharge and Pierce her brain ooh yikes
she's not going to be
okay they always go just
and they never listen just go AP [__]
ballistic come on got to get through
this maze as fast as you can go move now
go
now oh God girl run does she have
something on her legs you make it come
on you you got to keep
moving is so hot oh my God girl run wait
a
[Music]
minute go go go go go go come on
now running running running GN come on
now oh he's getting into the face oh my
God come
on my God no I don't want that no the
ladder at the end so just go under I'll
help
you oh my god oh I hate
it
ha hustle make it make it go go go go go
go feeling she's not going fast
enough o oh my God girl you going to
burn your face off Bo oh I hate face not
in the
face go oh my God oh my God there's got
to be a key it's going to be like the
keys down there is he inside of her
don't tell me oh it's up in there she oh
it's in him oh right the scar that we
saw yeah inside you yeah man untie it
let's
go puppy open you got 19 oh yeah she
ready she ready saw him open come on now
what you doing
need oh [__] girl just ask him chill
together oh this [__] is crazy no honey
honey oh he pushed her in the face what
the he was helping you this whole time
why are you doing this woman you're
going to die bro you're going to die too
late I mean sorry but you were so
selfish lawyer lady he literally told
you he you could have asked him and he
would have probably been like let's work
it out today you will experience the
meaning of sacrifice and you will see
the consequence for those who unjustly
hurt
others girl you got to listen to that
whole tape there's rules right see it
work what oh the cameras what'd you find
an abnormality in stm's fingerprint was
the contaminant we found at the site
already or did STM bring it in with him
yeah we're looking into the building's
function before it was abandoned stop
looking at oh my God you scar me I'm
sorry nothing scar is even happened I
know I I'm the worst we're trying to
descramble the tape to find the original
voice get ready he's going to kill y'all
also her face looks surprisingly good
for a bomb and going off in her face
right I agree she's had some time who
knows what the timeline is though could
have been like two weeks ago you're
coming right don't bring him with
you why do you trust him I know that she
doesn't but I'm like I guess might as
well keep him closer maybe it's they
leading him to a trap hope so
yeah see I knew she kept six that's I
was like where's that six at
I thought six held the reporter's
picture in it but I was wrong it has
somebody else I feel it has our our guy
which uh the detective yeah our new jigs
okay like that's his final yeah she's
going to test him hey who's in there is
that you yeah Shelby we're all in here
sir all six of us what the hell is going
on oh it's the
bullpen get us out of here you're
right oh yeah oh yeah I mean they were
bound to show up right they're helping
make the choices before you are six of
your most valuable Associates the ones
who find errors in policies but only two
can get off two okay remember the
mounted gun will continue to fire until
all six rounds are spent oh man God you
must press both buttons at Once In The
Box again doing so you'll give a
sacrifice of your
well well well I'm like conflicted about
about these games cuz like before it's
it's about individual choice right but
now it's about this specific guy's
decisions and all of these guys are just
who are involved they're involved but
they're just like Pawns in this guy's
lesson because they could each
individually have lessons they have to
learn themselves yeah
especially for them for sure I that's
why I thought they were going to be in a
room and have to learn stuff about
but I guess not you say we're only as
strong as the weakest L I'm the
strongest you can't let me die [__] him
I'm damn how fast they turn on each
other I have two kids you know them will
please
me yeah I don't like that that I don't
like that the way these games are
[Music]
oh yeah by by jigsaws definition They're
Not Innocent but he's not giving them a
choice they're just Pawns in this guy's
game game and this guy's oh God yikes my
parents are sick okay they need me I'm
all they have your parents hat you they
cut you off what shut up that's not true
you it is true I sit next to
you I'm no business that's the funniest
line I sit next to
[Laughter]
you God okay all right damn we're done
with that now rest of yall survived how
do they what happens now he only killed
two people we need to kill two more I
guess oh right he has to kill two more I
forgot two people get to walk
away you let him die you're racist don't
do
it
wow
okay but you cannot trust this [__]
damn right kill that guy yeah definitely
kill him that guy get he's got to go
he's got to go I know I just said this
would be about Fair trial but since
we're already
here okay yeah skip her and let the
other guy die obviously right or he's
going to kill her okay oh no he saved
her we saved
her and then the other ones die he keeps
the two women that guy's got to go yeah
that guy's totally
dead now can he just walk away cuz it's
just going to choose he's already made
his two choices so like now the three of
them still chooses four for him I know
but he's used his two he's only allowed
to save two right I did everything for
you look at me when you're killing me
you look at me oh look at me who okay
buddy say thank you Bank Daddy for
saving my life you're feeling
helpless right now you feeling helpless
fu yeah the parallels to three I see
them whoever made this tape had access
to some very impressive audio filtration
equipment I hope they have like a hidden
mic in there and they they make him like
talk right and then match it we have
some tricks of our own here can turn his
algorithm upside down and let us hear
what he really sounds like he's going to
kill you guys let's get at it you
okay seem a little
preoccupied I'm just anxious about the T
you don't say it my power feeling
helpless we getting there come on I
thought you had something to show
us throw that hot coffee on somebody
going throw the coffee all over all of
them on further analysis of tr's
fingerprints it was found that the uric
acid levels in the eing Glam residue
were inconsistent in other words when he
left his fingerprints on the latest
victim St was already dead now you're
hel got him you're feeling help coffee
oh s oh nice
interesting okay I knew it I knew it
damn all
right oh boy damn girl she just helped
you what are you doing you're an F you
can't do a head shot oh my God no no no
no she's going to be like you yeah
everyone got you on
tape hope the prence
outside coming that's so fast I don't
want it was
YY oh God don't leave there why this is
those are the things I don't like you're
being messy you would not do that you
work too hard to be too Reckless yeah
like what are we doing here oh that's
his hand okay he has his hand so what's
he oh he's going to take the hand back
down wrap it around the knife that he
just
dropped
see
okay okay been using them to to touch
[Music]
everybody I mean aren't there cameras
obviously there's cameras everywhere in
these
places it's
all there's no way there wouldn't be C
It's all under
yeah
maybe the wife's going to stop him maybe
the wife's going to be the one to take
him down cuz she doesn't want to do this
and I feel like six like we right we
think it's him he's six maybe that' be
the only thing that makes sense to keep
it to keep it hidden this
long I found something you want to see
it was at the location where John died
does it mean anything to
you what that you can pull it I love you
love you too
uh no you don't know what it does maybe
probably not what you think it does
right around a corner
three right as he gets there God I would
like climb up that thing climb up the
vence right oh God it releas is for
two it's going to release in hurri cage
God
be or on the
dad even
work oh God oh God I think I know what
it
is oh that's you have to wait get used
to me cuz I'm not going anywhere you
sure about
that Amanda you were with cight J
gide I don't know about this what do you
mean she's been good to
oh oh my God
listen to
me
a what you killed their child you know
it and I know it so do exactly as I say
kill
lenman or I will tell John what you
did wait how does he know
[Music]
that
yo
wow
what
[Music]
how
wa what she just like electrocuted him
in the in a good
[Music]
old what happens
now
I don't know buddy where does this go
from here you will never see your family
again oh so maybe now you can help
them what are you doing
here I know it's your birthday I'm going
to make it up to you I promise you
really standing up your sister for work
from your only family that's his sister
you [__] who's going to cover me now
you just killed me that's his family
that's his family cuz I was like why
would he be all up on his sister in
front of his wife no
okay okay oh man this is the best twist
since two hello Tara the man before you
just made the sacrifices to save the
life of a loved one to save your
husband's life he chose not to now you
will be given the power there we go okay
this man the opportunity to continue
living or will you dispense the same
death sentence he issued your husband
live or
die
oh it's not my
game oh that's a head
thing
oh Amanda the one that has done
it wow she didn't do it to Amanda she's
doing it to him John left you five
envelopes 61 was for me yeah okay y Yep
this is John's
will so why was he trained though and
then the reason I'm doing this is
because I couldn't forgive myself for
what you might do to someone else please
no oh all right she's going to kill him
I thought they let him go yeah please oh
o this is going to be brutal oh my god
oh is she going to kill kill you no she
can't have it in her I don't think she
has in your son's right there she don't
got that dog in her I can't but the son
might have that dog son's going to run
and just pull it right I
can you
[Music]
mother Sun get bured hell Sun get that
dog
oh oh with the acid not that oh no oh no
oh this is horrible oh my Gody no this
is horrible oh God this is the
worst acid syringes from the oh
wow oh watch no you think it's the
living will have ultimate judgment over
you because the dead will have no claim
over your soul
soul we'll see about that he said yeah
well he s
[Applause]
that's crazy oh game over over no no
wel whoa oh oh what's his game what's
his game I guess it's just done like he
doesn't even get to get out right he
just is like he isn't get it oh what is
he doing what is he doing is he going to
bash his hand so he can pull it through
I bet you he is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's not he's built too many of these
yeah okay she's your test
detective
okay but you don't have a key right he
doesn't have
[Music]
a do we got it in
him oh no what John's final request you
want a chance I'll give you a
chance wao oh he escaped wa oh god
without his face his
cheek oh oh oh my
god wow oh my goodness wow
okay oh he's coming back looking like
the Joker guarantee oh yeah face all
stitched up
wow okay right right side all stitched
up next
wow so wife the final chapter is the
next one but there's three more after
this what's what's the deal that's no
Final Chapter oh no so wifey was in on
it for a long time but she wanted it to
stop and
now she she betrothed the last game but
he got out he got got out he escaped so
what the next movie is him getting
revenge now that's like how is there
more testing after this
what okay so the last three shots were
him no cheek wifey
and what they showed wifey and one more
person of a quick shot they they showed
um they showed Amanda they showed Amanda
was it Amanda Amanda was the girl who
died in I know but she's dead they
showed someone that was still alive
right
I don't know still with I don't know
there's some twists and turns in here
this this was good but in the beginning
I thought I'll just be on real quick in
the beginning I thought it was a little
slow for some reason I was like oh that
I wasn't as engaged until we got like
maybe 20 minutes in then I was like cool
we're we're moving here um wow I did not
think that detective was going to live
through this one but I'm also like the
one thing in my brain just goes like I
get that he was a copy cat he was being
taught a lesson but then why train him
to go through all of this and then know
all along that you're going to give your
wife his card to get rid of him and not
carry on your your whole thing right as
being saw because he he trained him he
did all the juice and I'm like well I
guess eventually the game has to end
it's all probably part of his plan I get
it I'm just like he put in a lot of
effort to train him we that was mainly
the last one showing us how much he was
there and involved with all of the kills
in order for him to like learn the
lesson and how to do it and I'm like
yeah but then why would the last game be
taking him out I guess cuz like he never
learned his lesson he never learned his
lesson maybe I don't know well I think
we'll probably find out the next we'll
find out I know I'm just like oh the
theories it's fun to theorize yeah I had
like mixed emotions about this one I I I
would say overall I walked away liking
it more than the last two mhm uh cuz
yeah this is the first time I've been
like shocked like like Blown Away by The
Twist since the second one to be honest
with you cuz yeah I did not see some of
those things coming I saw his name being
in the envelope coming but yeah the
whole twist with the girlfriend and the
wife cuz they the movie is is cool
because they make you think like you're
smart then like they they give you
enough Clues to make you think like you
know what's going on but then it flips
it on his head like no you actually
don't know what's going on and this is
the game we're actually playing oh man I
was so good I mean I think I think those
parts were good I think the stuff that
had me a little bit more like given the
movie the side eye was the fact that at
least from the beginning it seemed like
John was this guy who was like had this
moral principle in this code about the
fact that he didn't let
people just die it was like everyone had
to play a game to go through the lesson
because they've all don't have
appreciation for life they've gone
through something that like makes them I
don't know they're all their souls are
tainted in a way but all of these games
was like it's a game teaching someone
else a game or it's a game that someone
else is playing ultimately so it's like
three layers deep but some of these
people were just pawns like the guy in
the beginning he just he just smoked too
many damn cigarettes he didn't do
nothing wrong to nobody but he had to
die and then these other people granted
they were shitty they worked for the guy
who holds when that got killed uh by the
but you know they didn't get really a
fair shake at it either they were just
there as part of the the game for this
guy which which the game was really
about the family so that part kind
of like yeah it's like losing a soul
that's not meant to be there like the
game they didn't learn anything from it
even though he thought maybe they should
yeah it kind of contradicts the what
John was saying in the other movies was
like we don't just kill people to kill
people this is about like the game
teaching people lessons giving them
appreciation for life and yeah I think
that part didn't really didn't really
track with what they
established but that being said I do
think that the ending twist was was
really satisfying and did not see it
coming um yeah I I had a great time with
this one overall I would say this is
probably the third best for me I would
say this is probably I'd give this one
like a
7.5 yeah I mean the games were fun and
going back to what he was saying
obviously the secretary the older lady
who had the kids like she did nothing
wrong and I don't even know if the young
kid in the beginning did anything wrong
the only people that I thought were
going to be on display was the bullpen
and him which is why I kept saying we
got to get to the bullpen of people
because they're the ones that are making
the bulk of the decisions to like leave
these people hanging when they're when
they're at their worst which is terrible
so it's like oh Karma yes but um I think
you're right in in seeing like oh it
seems like the the the games have gotten
sloppy with the moral code
who we at least for most of
themed to be learning a lesson and most
of what we saw here at least in the
beginning kills didn't really learn a
lesson not even the bullpen which I was
looking forward to of all of them
learning a lesson I mean I think they
figured it out like oh we've done bad
things with policies and people but I
thought they were really going to learn
like why they were there right um but
they didn't we we stayed on that guy
which I know we were like why why are we
just following that guy and then we
learn it's really a game for the family
at the end that they get to hold the you
know his life in their hands and yeah I
was surprised by that that she that she
killed him I mean no that the son I was
not surprised by that I thought she was
not going to be able to do it and then a
little bit at the end I was like that
kid is g to man teenage hormones he's
gonna be like Emer you die now and he
did but the ass is going in there the
games in this were uh were cool they
were intense they were they were
different uh I liked the steam one the
running with the steam that was very
inventive and put that made that kept me
on the edge of my seat that made me very
uncomfortable and also that girl goes
wild and that guy just saved your life
he was burning off of his face to let
you run through a thing and you just
come out with your saw I love how they
put people in these positions the second
they free and have a choice they're
like they're literally like animals at
the zoo which is maybe a slight metaphor
that we were missing in the beginning
and we see it now cuz that girl I mean
they none of them just stay and listen
and are like let's just like take it in
except for a little bit the mom and the
son at the end right they did take it in
to try to like we got to figure out what
we're doing here um I still am kind of
like what did the reporter who is his
sister learn all she was really doing
was
sensationalizing the news but she was
still giving she was still saying the
truth so I mean I guess she didn't die
but she had to see her brother die cuz I
think that was her brother the the money
man not anyway anyhow I'm like I assume
she'll she's figured it out like what
the lesson is don't don't do that but
well these movies are chapters more so
than like complete story so we'll
probably get more of her in the next
movie most likely them all see them all
see all the dang films I we're going
through them we're going through them
we're like we're we're what six deep now
so we got four more of these to go
that's a lot that's a lot of movies so
you you were putting it 7.5 I'll put it
at like I was I was going to say around
the same I'm going to say seven only
because in the beginning I don't know
why it wasn't feeling that like oh I'm
in it and I was really engaged I felt
like uh in the beginning you'll see I
didn't
we nothing was really happening I was
silent and that gives me a clue because
I was like dang I need to be saying
something so that we so that the editors
have something to cut to right right um
and I didn't feel I didn't feel en urged
I just felt like oh I need to take it in
and I didn't feel en urged to say
anything and that's why I'm bringing it
down to a seven I that's the only reason
why but I do enjoy that this is shot a
little less like uh um a TV it felt more
handheld a little more cinematic um the
games were cool
and I mean all the actors were great I
never I was never really taken out by
any of the actors which is excellente
I'll leave it at a seven you got any
last
thoughts uh I will say I did appreciate
the fact that it was a parallel between
three and the fact that it's like two
people going on a journey one person is
about the people three is about the
people that he felt have wronged him and
like putting him in a position to be
able to save them versus people in uh
this one where is kind of teaching him a
lesson about morality except you find
out it's not actually that it's about
this family's choice so I thought that
was very cool kind of flipped that on
its head but uh yeah overall that flip
was cool we both were like that is what
we have missed I think from the first
two is is us going wait
what which I felt mostly in one and two
um and then this one finally kind of
gave us that a little bit more which is
great maybe three did that a little bit
but it was I remember us going it's not
the same yeah it wasn't the same
surprise yeah the twist didn't get me as
much in three but this one this one
shocked me uh but yeah I en I enjoyed it
overall and yeah I'm excited I'm excited
I'm excited to keep going we're doing
this saw Journey with you guys so please
don't forget leave a like leave a
comment ring the bell uh do all the
right things tell us how cool we are we
love you so much thanks for hanging out
and we will see you on the next one
bye